a la reelección presidencial no es el
único asunto que por esos días se aborda
en la casa blanca antes de esos comicios
del 3 de noviembre el presidente de
donald trump busca reemplazar una
vacante en la corte suprema en tiempo
récord es un proceso que en promedio
tarda 70 días y queda en 41 para acudir
a las urnas en la unión americana
trump quiere reemplazar a ruth báder
ginsburg un icono progresista cuyo
fallecimiento ha abierto un nuevo frente
contra los demócratas y es que la
oposición se niega que trump haga una
designación vitalicia y en un año
electoral como parte de la designación
el comité judicial del senado debe
interrogar al nominado de champ en una
audiencia pública este comité los lidera
lindsey graham cercano al mandatario
kamala harris candidata demócrata a la
vicepresidencia también integra ese
grupo si la mayor parte de ese comité
aprueba el nominado se llega al senado
en donde hace falta una mayoría simple
de 51 votos en esta cámara los
republicanos tienen una mayoría de 53
votos pero hay dos senadores moderados
que han expresado reparos a esta
votación en el hipo
en caso de que se llegara un empate el
vicepresidente de mike pence tendría la
última palabra paradójicamente la
elección más rápida en la historia fue
la de ruth báder en 1993 con 50 días así
que en caso de que trump consiguiera
sacar adelante a su candidato sentaría
un nuevo precedente